los líderes de las siete democracias
occidentales económicamente más fuertes
y representantes de la Unión Europea
están en Japón en la agenda aparecen los
asuntos globales más desafiantes que
deben afrontarse en este momento
el mundo ahora enfrentan múltiples
crisis como la crisis climática la
pandemia y la invasión rusa de Ucrania
el g7 debe responder de manera efectiva
los problemas importantes que enfrenta
la comunidad internacional
en el centro de la escena aparece el
conflicto en el este de Europa al mismo
tiempo que reafirmaron el apoyo a
Ucrania volvieron a ampliar las
sanciones contra Rusia para limitar
ingresos comerciales de metales y
diamantes restringir exportaciones de
maquinaria Industrial herramientas y
tecnologías y castigos a 200 entidades
que ayudan a su producción y capacidad
energética esto mientras espera la
intervención de wallodimir serensky
durante el fin de semana
Allí se decidirán cosas muy importantes
y por lo tanto la presencia de nuestro
presidente es absolutamente esencial
para defender nuestros intereses
otro punto álgido fue el poderío
económico de China ausente en esta
Cumbre el g7 Busca métodos para
fortalecer la cooperación entre ellos
sin atentar contra el desarrollo de la
segunda economía más grande del mundo en
tanto Instagram a China a desescalar el
desarrollo nuclear precisamente desde
Hiroshima donde la detonación de una
bomba nuclear estadounidense puso el
punto final a la Segunda Guerra Mundial
en 1945